hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren ihr seht es bereits hinter
eingeblendet fortnight sie sind sechs
ist gerade raus gekommen deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht hey
hey ich hab mir gedacht ich hab mir das
einfach mal direkt runter mache direkt
das update kaufen wir direkt den bettel
passt mit 25 stufen schon mal damit ich
mich dieses kleider aus die hier habe
das ist nicht die einzige figur die
heute mit dabei sondern auch noch der
hier
wolfgang a das ist max
er sieht ihr halt so krass ähnlich eines
der krassen features die season 6 mit
sich gebracht hatte sind haustiere ihr
seht schon auf meinem rücken hier da ist
ein hund der passt ja nicht hier dann
kriegt er sich so hin wenn ich hoch her
geht er wieder dorthin und wir sind
direkt im schlachten bus max und ich
landen jetzt gerade hier im sommer
mysteriösen ort und ihr seht stets aufs
neue steine also wenn man die verwendet
dann wird man unsichtbar ich sehe halt
gar nichts und die acht doch jetzt
warten wir heißen die dementoren alter
das sieht genauso aus wie diese die
mentorinnen fort er in harry potter
heißen überhaupt die methoden also max
meinte jetzt gerade das wenn ich vor dem
stein wenn einfach mal links theo mein
gott ich kann dadurch gehen ja wie geil
ist das denn stellen vor
du hast eigentlich voll die schlechten
sachen und dann gegner hat so richtig
heftige base licher aufgebaut und du
kannst einfach mit diesem länger
durchgehen
wie krass aber man kann auch rechts
gedrückt halten dann kann man den modus
quasi einfach wieder verlassen
allerdings ist das nicht das einzige was
dazu gekommen ist freunde sondern im
blut lag ist der würfel versunken
baumax ja leute und dieser würfel der im
blut lag versunken ist es jetzt so hoch
geflogen auferstanden keine ahnung und
da oben ist das gebäude was sonst immer
hier damit besteht hier unten ist
derzeit irgendwo ein strudel da oben ist
dieser würfel und man kann hier wirklich
einfach mit zum aufschwung kann man
quasi die ganze zeit herum fliegen also
jetzt fliege ich hier rum und dann lande
ich oben theoretisch einfach bei dem
haus so und bin quasi jetzt übel hoch
das sind so die wesentlichen sachen die
eigentlich neu dazu gekommen sind halt
noch ein paar kleinigkeiten und so
weiter aber das krasseste es eigentlich
wirklich für mich erstmal das haustier
weil es ist einfach ein kleiner süßer
hund und man will natürlich nicht aus
diesem grund irgendetwas zustößt
deswegen haben max und ich uns die hund
haustier beschützen fordert sechs diesen
challenge genauso heiß wie wir haben
seine challenge überlegt und zwar werden
max und ich nun in eine duo runde gehen
und ich darf keinen schaden erleiden
also ich darf keinen schluss abkriegen
ich darf mich von einer klippe
runterfallen ich darf nicht keine ahnung
irgendwie was machen weil mein hund muss
überleben und ich muss diesen hund die
mich selbst beschützen ok sieht schon
das wiederholt sich so dahin fest
da landen welche okay hier können wir
können es nicht riskieren da und muss
ich bleiben müssen uns auf jeden fall
waren die hunde kümmern also ich tanz
gleich mal für den der das war mega mega
danke dafür dass sich direktversicherer
glaube ich die sache ist ich darf jetzt
hat keinen schaden können ich habe nicht
mal materialien oder so wie geht es dem
hund der hund der angst oder so meerdorf
gut drauf wenn er angst hat vielleicht
sollten wir den mal sonntags zuhause
bauen seine hütte oder so dann würde ich
das machen ja leute so sieht dann die
hundehütte hieraus hier kann ein
bisschen rumlaufen hier vorne machen wir
dann futternapf bin oder irgend sowas
kommt dann müssen wir eben kurz was
hinschmeißen zum knabbern dort hat er
sein stückchen die hat er seine
seinen schlafplatz cool ja mal gucken
freut er sich darüber freute sich der
freut sich wirklich nein ich hab jetzt
bekomme ich hab jetzt bekommt über
betrage hier ist ob sie noch okay geht
oder und linke sieht immer noch total
happy aus ich glaube jetzt nicht so weit
okay ich gehe trotzdem sicherheitshalber
man die hundehütte die sache ist
allerdings immer wenn ich angeschossen
werde beziehungsweise schaden erleide
muss ich das beste item was ich gerade
habe wegschmeißen und da ich gerade nur
ein verband habe und eine waffe muss
leider die waffe jetzt dran glauben es
sieht so richtig krass aus eigentlich so
weit so richtig viel freilauf kannst du
hier so rumlaufe da vorne seine ecken
aber dahinter heutigen leute da da da
habe ich eine graue ar mega gut dann
kann nichts mehr passieren oder halter
der hunde so safe jetzt den das feiert
der absatz von dem hunde ding das ist
übel der guten trick ja dann eigentlich
um vergleichen und zu wahren oder der
guckt halt nutze die relevanten partner
bist sonst wäre das richtig heftig oder
ich gerade wenn er so einfach normal
bisschen rum schild mein gegner kommt
kommt er so verängstigen gegen die
richtung oder so
[Musik]
die sache ist guck mal wenn ich mit dem
golfcart vater ist der hund in dem sitz
sieht nicht so aus als wäre das
irgendwie sehr gesund das nicht so gut
für ihn glaube ich glaube du solltest
besser fahren und ich stelle mich
einfach wir sind erstmal wieder in der
zone
ok ich muss ich muss leider was runter
werfen jetzt und zwar meine grüne hr ich
gerade erst bekommen habt ihr den hund
geht's wieder gut oder hunde
ja ja ich glaube dass viele leute da
rechts und leute müssen echte erstmal
auf den hund aufpasste ok ja ich will ja
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht entschieden ich
würde das dem hund hier gut geht warum
schießt du und beschattet wir müssen wir
klug müssen ich nehme die karre dass die
karten eben schnell ok sehr gut planen
wir außen rum schnell schnell nicht so
gelassen nein nein
als ob es gerade wirklich passiert der
arme hund dadurch für ein ende oder an
der stelle wenn ich das heute gewinne
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren max und ich habe uns
einfach gedacht okay fortnight die neue
season 6 rausgekommen sind veränderungen
an der maps zu stellen aber es sind auch
haustiere mit dazugekommen ein hund eine
schildkröte ein drache glaube ich ich
habe natürlich direkt den hund geholt
und wir haben uns gedacht okay wir
müssen diesen hund um gottes willen
beschützen
das hat nicht ganz geklappt
[Musik]
drei plänen die kommentare wie ich den
hund eventuell nennen soll und ob ich
eventuell mal demnächst riemen soll
vielleicht auch mit max dann würde ich
nicht mehr darum kümmern dass ich meinen
twitter-account zurückkriegen weil ich
hab das passwort leider vergessen
tape.tv geht da mal drauf und folgt mir
und abonniert und und was man doch sonst
noch so machen kann und leisten leica
schreibt ein kommentator der videos
machen soll und schau
[Musik]